اعرف استوديو الان زميل وسيم نادالي العقد
للتو من اوكرانيا وسيمه اهلا بك جلد في
منطقه تاخير سنه اودس الصف محيطها الجنوب
الاوكراني الذي كان طبعا استهدف بكثافه
القصف وشاهدنا ايضا هذا الانسحاب الروسي
من حيث ما ابرز الشهادات التي سمعت اليها
كيف يعيش السكان تحت وطاه هذه الحرب وايضا
العائدون الى منطقه المحرره نعم منذ ان
وصلنا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه في اوكرانيا
اشتغلنا همم في هذه المنطقه باعتبار
المستجدات التي وقعت في ذلك الوقت طبعا
شاهدنا العديد من المشاهد التي لا تخلو من
الطابع الرمز طبعا همم واهمها هو خروج
القوات الروسيه من مدينه خيرسون طبعا همم
نحن وصلنا بعد ايام قليله من انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من مدينه خلص ولكن همم
الوزاره الدفاع حددت اجراءاتي الدخول وبعد
ان دخلت القوات الروسيه جاء دور الاعلام
لدخول همم مدينه خرسن وكانت هناك جوله
صحفيه منظمه من قبل او وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه الى خلصن وما لفت انتباه خاصه
عند وصولنا الى مدينه خلص وعند دخول لمشار
في هذه المدينه الاستقبال الذي حاضينا به
كنا تقريبا
صحفي من انحاء العالم وكنا في حافلات يعني
تقريبا اربع حافلات نقالاتنا من مدينه
نيكولايس وحفيظه وحقيقه باستقبال الابطال
وكان لسانه حالي الاوكرانيين وخاصه السكان
المحليين الذي الذين كانوا منقطعنا حقيقه
عن العالم
يقول تعال اعلام انظر ما فعل به الروس من
الروس طيره هذه الفتره وكانت كل الاعلام
ترفرف وكانت الهتافات عند عند وصولنا طبعا
همم طبعا همم كانت وكان هناك همم الرئيس
مرسينيسكيل الذي جاء بالمناسبه لي
للاحتفال بخروج القوات الروسيه طبعا
الساحه المدينه حقيقه عندما وصلنا كانت
تحولت الى منصه
لمساعده الانسانيه
للقاء بين الاوكرانيين وبين همم الجنود
وبين الاعلام التي انتباهي صراحه عندما
شاهدت همم هناك همم
المتنقلين للشرائح الهواتف الذكيه همم
لاحظت تدافعا كبيرا من قبل الاوكرانيين
على الشراء هذه الشرائح طبعا المشهد يبدو
بسيطه ولكن همم عندما تشاهد هذا المشهد
همم عاده تشاهده في المطارات عندما تصل
الى بلد ولكن همم عندما تعود الى الوطن
ولكن هذا المشهد يدل على ان الوطن عاد الى
الاوكرانيين الموجودين هناك والذين يريدون
ان يكونوا على التواصل مع البلد طبعا اا
لاحظته كذلك العديد من الاوكرانيين حول
همم يعني اجهزه الاستقبال والاجهزه
الانترنت الفضائيه باعتبار ان الانترنت
كانت منقطعه حول مقامص الكهرباء لان
الكهرباء منقطع طبعا وكانوا كانوا متلهفين
ومتشوقين لاستخدام الانترنت حتى يتصل
بالعالم وكان دخول القوات الاوكرانيه ليس
فقط تحرير هذه المدينه وانما نافذه العالم
فتحت امام
الاوكرانيين اوكرانيين السكان المحليين
الذين همم الذين عاشوا الظروفا صعبه في ظل
وجود القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه همم اثناء همم تواجدك هناك كيف
يعيش هؤلاء الاوكرانيون في العتمه بعيدا
عن الكهرباء عن الماء كل ما يلزم خصوصا
وان الشتاء على الابواب والشتاء
بس في بلدك اوكراني على ذكر البناء
التحتيه حتى الوصول من ميكو لايف الى
مدينه مدينه
خلصن الطريق ليس طويلا تقريبا 80 كم ولكن
الوصول يستوجب ساعتين لماذا لان هذه
الطريقه استهدفتها الصواريخ الروسيه كذلك
هناك اثار الدبابات التقينا مثلا في مدينه
ميكوراي ونعلم جيدا مدينه منكو لايف كانت
همم كان الماء منقطعا على هذه المدينه
بسبب قطع الروس المزرعه الماء من مدينه
الى مدينه ميكو لايف التقينا بعائله كانت
تعيش في مراه في مراه همم في مدينه ميكو
لايف كانت غادرت شقتها لان لا يوجد فيها
الماء الكهرباء ولا وسائل للتدفئه
وهناك بنتان كانتا تعيشان في القبو في هذا
المراب وعندما تحدثنا اليهما لمسنا
التفاؤل والامل وخاصه انهما السعيد لماذا
لان هما تمكنا من مشاهده الرسوم المتحركه
على شاشه التلفزيون في قبو رطب يفتقد الى
كل ابسط مقومات العيش الكريم احدى همم
احدى هاتين البنتين كانت حزينه لماذا لان
قطتها لا يمكن ان تعيش معها في هذا المكان
الصعب طبعا همم نفهم ان حتى ولو في هذه
الظروف الصعبه هناك من تعود على هذا
التعايش مع هذا الامر هناك التقينا
همم ذهبنا الى احد القرى التي يصعب الوصول
اليها حقيقه نحن همم سيارتنا همم انزلقت
وسط الاوحال للوصول الى هذه ولم لم يعني
نستطيع الخروج من الاوحال الا ما همم
تقدمت الينا همم سياره اخرى المساعده
الخروج من المحل لوصول الى قريه همم كانت
تحت السيطره سيطره القوه الروسيه والسجن
وكان تحول الى قاعده عسكريه للروس ومكان
ل- اا تخزين الذخائر التقينا حد سكانها
هذه القرى همم تمكن من اجلاء عائلته ام
زوجته وبناته ولكن ذو ظل واحيدا كان يعمل
وفقد عمله ويعيش على مساعدات القوه
الروسيه التي تقدمها ولو كانت قليله همم
لكن ابرز ما قاله هو عمليه الاهانه التي
تلقاها من قوه الروسيه عمليه همم حينما
كان يخرج مثلا في الشارع ك- هناك بعض من
الجنود قالوا له انت لم تتعذب بالشكل
الكافي ولكن سنرى كيف همم تجري همم مسافه
100 متر واطلقوا الطلقات بالاسلحه حتى
يجري ويشاهدونه وكيف يجري طبعا هذه بعض من
المشاهد الكثيره التي يرويها السكان
المحليه طبعا همم ما اردته ان اقول انه
حتى او في ظل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
حاليا وتوافذ القافله الانسانيه من كل
الجهات الجهات همم الدوليه همم الا ان
همم
المساعدات التي تظل غير كافيه باعتبار ان
هناك موجه برد وهناك القوات الروسيه لا
تريد ان تتراجع بتلك السهوله وان الضربات
لا تزال متواصله على المحطه الكهرباء ونحن
عشنا يعني بعض الفترات التي قطع فيها
التيار الكهربائي وعندما ينقطع الكهرباء
ينقطع الماء تنقطع وسائل الاتصال وتنقطع
كل سبل العيش لذلك يبدو ان العمليه غير لن
تقف في هذه المرحله وان
القادم يبدو اسوء ان لم يتم حل المشكله
بين القوات بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا
الحرب في جنوب اوكرانيا شكرا لك